[Music]
well this week is very exciting for us
and i don't want to make it about us but
it is our show
so uh we need to tell you how excited we
are that our first movie a movie that we
wrote and directed is coming out
this weekend this friday this friday if
you're listening to this on friday it's
today it's coming out today and if
you're listening on saturday it's
yesterday so
and if you're let's watching now yeah
and if you're listening in 2024 it came
out a couple years ago so why haven't
you seen it yet it's called lady of the
matter you're probably all sick of us
talking about it but
we're excited about it so we're going to
talk about it yeah so deal with it
september 17th this friday
it is available to watch you can watch
on apple tv stream it you can you can
wherever you buy movies and if you wait
a few days more september 21st it'll be
available on blu-ray and dvd so um
we hope people watch it
and like it well yeah but mostly watch
it and we hope people stick around for
what we're about to do which is the
podcast and we hope they like that
we're just very hopeful
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your hopeful host justin long
[Music]
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my
co-host and co-director
christian equally hopeful yep we're
hopeful that people like it you know
both of you hopeful that people like our
movie
by the way if you see us
out in the world
uh and you've seen the movie and you
didn't like it yeah don't say anything
just you know
just like avoid eye contact all together
yeah because if you just look at us in
any way we'll know we can we'll see it
written on your face that you didn't
like i'll be very sensitive we're very
soon we have very thin skin so um
just uh you know and don't go on
instagram and say
whatever because we'll read it because
we're weak also
it's not going to be for everyone let's
face it i'm not going to read stuff
actually there's you know there's a lot
of fart jokes and dick jokes and i think
far jokes are for everyone i think that
is an equal opportunity all right well i
don't think they are i don't think
they're for our parents for example like
george plimpton probably he's not going
to like you know
but um
i don't know
but
if there is an afterlife i imagine
there's a screening room and grandma's
gonna see it grandma was always very
supportive of um
the movies i did and she uh she'd be so
excited but it's a very fun movie it's a
buddy comedy about a kind of a slacker
stoner
lady a nerdwell a nerdwell who gets a
job working as
a tour guide at a
old historic manner
and
she's playing the role of a kind of a
locally famous woman reoccupied the
house and she's reenacting
this character and the woman she's
reenacting
the ghost of her she does not like judy
greer does not like how she's being
portrayed so she takes offense to it and
uh tries to
teach hannah the main character how to
uh behave like her be a lady be a lady
how to be like you know what's so funny
sometimes when i hear you describe it i
just had this this thought i think um
how that's a good that's kind of a good
idea
that's so arrogant but um it was so fun
for us to
flesh it out to write it and then god
shooting it was just
i i mean it was stressful beyond belief
but um
some of the the most stressful moments
of my life but also
some of the best like and sometimes
within the same day you know it was such
a what do they call that a roller
coaster yes and i feel like a bachelor
contestant i would also say one of the
best they overuse that
they do i would also say one of the best
aspects of making the movie is
was
getting to work with our lead actress oh
man and having the amazing fortune
uh of her wanting to do it i know i was
um see at first i thought she was just
being nice and like um
communicating when we center the script
and she was so
sweet about wanting to read you know i
just thought she because she's such a
nice person
um she's from new zealand and uh not to
say all kiwis are nice but the the ones
i've met are and um and it was such a
thrill when she wrote back and and we
realized she was actually interested in
the thing itself in doing it yeah we had
been such big fans of her work and
justin knew her personally he had worked
with her so they had a friendship um but
i just knew her as an actress and
i mean if you know her as an actress
you can't not be a fan of her acting she
means she's that kind of actress she and
she's also our guest today her name is
melanie linski she is uh one of my
favorite i mean i
i don't think i say this too often do i
that she's maybe i do but i thought you
were being sarcastic no i i guess i do
but i mean at this time
but uh she really is one of my favorite
actors and um
yeah like like christian said we were
just so
thrilled to have her
want to do our script it meant so much
to us and then when we shot it um
it meant that much more to see how
committed she was to the script i mean
she it was it was a low budget movie and
so
there weren't a lot of um it wasn't a
cushy job for an actor uh and especially
for mel because she was
she had just had a baby a couple months
earlier and so she was breastfeeding and
i didn't know this because we are too
nordic christian because we we're men
and um we're selfish and we don't have
to learn about the other jokes for
yourself okay well when it comes to
things about breastfeeding and whatnot i
didn't know how much that i mean i
should have guessed but how much that
depleted i didn't know that either that
energy you don't bother have to not know
that breastfeeding depletes a woman
because it takes away nutrients that she
should be getting um
yeah and so she was such
i mean god she was such a
champion to to yeah
it was a huge understatement to say she
was a trooper but she was a trooper i
almost said trooper trooper sounded too
cute and like and it didn't um trooper
is not a big enough word no i know and
she was like whatever the word is for
like a huge trooper yeah she was a huge
trooper like a paratrooper okay um she
is and so she went from being somebody
that i admired and really liked um in
life because christian said i did get
the fortune to work with her uh to
somebody that i i really love i i love
mel now and um
i i get emotional when i think about
what she's done for us and and how just
how much
joy she brought to that experience i
would say most people know her from her
role on two and a half men and that's
that's um
her more like most broad
thing broadly known thing that she's
done
uh but other people will know her from
like a million great independent films
yeah that she's been in so many we talk
about one called the intervention um
she's in heavenly creatures uh but ever
after which was a big movie she's in oh
you know she gets recognized a lot for
which we didn't talk about a sweet home
alabama oh right she um well soon she'll
be recognized hopefully yes for her
starring role her brilliant starring
role in lady of the manor yes people
will out this friday right oh i stepped
on your plug [ __ ] uh yes we're so
excited uh and i'm excited for you to
hear
me uh catch up with her uh here we go
our our leading lady of lady of the
manor
the
delightful incredibly talented
very very kind our friend melanie linsky
life could be a dream sweetheart
this episode of life is short is brought
to you in part by audible gather the
family for story time magic with audible
listen to imaginative heartwarming and
festive stories original podcasts and
more brought to life by incredible
performers enjoy brand new audible
originals like the cinnamon bear and
exclusives like the christmas pig by jk
rowling fire up modern classics like
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
and so many more all-time favorites
now's the time to listen together go to
audible.com
listen together
that's audible.com
listen together listen now only from
audible
hello
[Music]
get out of here what what are you sorry
for it always like
no that's me i love it i love when other
people are late i do too are you late
i'm always at least a minute or two late
oh i'm always like 10 minutes late great
teen
teen i thought that yesterday i was like
he's just gonna do my own accent back to
me after an hour
where is jason let's get him in here
let's get him to cameo in this one
all right i'll be yeah
okay and i'll get my other headphones
just in case here it comes okay so
melanie's getting jason here he comes
yes
so
and look your blonde hair oh yeah
it's very tall
oh okay
okay melanie was quick to point that out
she's
actively
embarrassed
um
where she needs to pre-emptively yeah
yeah that's fine
because it was for a job several months
ago and i just kept it
like
super
cool it's pretty cool i have to point
out that melanie does look genuinely
embarrassed and
yeah
he's adorable he's looks good i think
i know so he's not even that bad
so i can't really be like listen you
gotta do something because he still
looks so cute it's just so jarring it's
a very different it really does a lot
yeah i i made it worse by buying some
kind of thing in the store that was like
sun
bleed for blonde i was like oh this is
for me now
um so chase the the job is done the
platinum the job is that oh it's a lot
it's long
it was done in may yeah
it was one day it was one day of work
what
what yeah it was like a flash forward uh
you know like into the future and i said
hey i'm not married to my hair length or
color do it do what you will and i said
what if we reach only the top he said
let's do it i can see the thought bubble
above melanie which is but i'm married
to it yeah yeah
she's like just short of giving me an
ultimatum it's been like
stronger and stronger suggestions to
change well he had to go and participate
in this abc documentary about his father
yes
it's a serious thing yes and so i was
like
well it looks like it's time you know
yeah expecting
yeah no i chose to keep it i'm blonde in
that special with no explanation
well i feel like your dad would have
laughed about it he did and also he
didn't even remember but after
slingblade he had that like very weird
haircut
yeah that also was sort of lightened and
he kept that for
quite a while
oh really he would he would just keep it
here yeah my volunteer is an homage to
my dad if that's okay
um
who passed i don't know if you know that
he passed
yeah man
this is horrible for me because now i'm
just not gonna sound funny oh get out of
here you've been so funny already
come on jason tell her she's so funny
she's the funniest
the other day we asked our daughter the
other day
but i said who's the funniest
in the family and she said mama
and
is data very funny and she said he's
goofy yeah but in the in kid world i
think goofy might be might be higher
than funny i think
probably it's probably that
she's like you're witty you're wittier
yeah yeah you're pithier
yeah
he's goofy yeah
that's so funny i know how is that
perfect little nugget she's so cute oh
my gosh
man
miss her so much um i know she loves you
she still talks about you that's great
that's great well it's been a year and
um
you know obviously we're getting excited
we
we're going to talk a lot about it on
the show but um
what what is the last year been like
because you've been working a lot you've
been
working during all this for the most
part right i didn't work
until
the end of 2020.
so like i got an offer to do a movie and
i was so nervous about the movie
um
and then i went and did two episodes of
young sheldon
it was fun it was super fun
so fun yeah i bet that's the chuck
laurie show it's a chuck glory show and
so you know i know chuck and he asked me
and
i it was i was very grateful
to be with people i knew and have kind
of like a practice run was two and a
half men because that that strikes me as
something that was unique for you like
that was a different
type of
acting medium that you had done or had
you had experience with multicam stuff
well i was like
24 when i
auditioned for that show and i had just
gotten my green card
i had just been deemed an alien of
extraordinary ability
thank you you are yes which you are so i
was able to go out for a pilot season
i'd never done pilot season before
because there just wasn't enough like
time to get a visa to do a pilot so it
was my first ever pilot and i was just a
guest star and i was like that seems
kind of fun to do like a guest star and
a sitcom and then they asked me to be a
regular after the pilot oh wow so and
was that a difficult decision mel or was
it like oh no bro to me now that we've
talked about this like what a fantasy
that sounds like yeah but but at the
time when you're 24 and i was a little
like pretentious about like oh being
stuck on a show and like did that factor
in at all i was kind of
not in a great place
um
i had agents who
didn't seem that excited about me
you know and i just was kind of like
and they were like why not
so i i thought okay you know i did have
all those feelings about like what does
this mean am i now going to be like a
sitcom person right
and i did a year and at the end of the
year i had a conversation with chuck and
i said i feel like i'm a wacky neighbor
my worst nightmare
um
i just remember this one episode it was
i had one scene and i was pushing angus
the little boy around in the chair he
was wrapped in bandages
someone's the half man and someone said
what are you doing and i said we're
playing mummy in a chair
that was all i did that week
i just was like ah
mummy in a chair it's a it was such a
weird and funny joke and i actually
really liked it but
yeah yeah
but i don't know i decided to think like
what if there was
more like
you know i missed the independent movies
i've been doing i missed getting to do a
supporting part in something you know i
would imagine that world and i'm not
saying like god there's great acting
that's possible in that world and you've
done it and and we've all seen it um
but but i imagine it
must present some difficulties
you know in terms of
being really grounded and um
sad and fulfilled i guess
the fulfillment part was the biggest
part because there's not a lot of places
for the character to go it's established
i felt really lucky because i was
playing a character who was a genius a
billionaire
like completely insane
so there were a lot of things happening
like once i decided to leave the show as
a regular after season two and i just
came back when i could oh that's great
um i'm so lucky that they let me do that
yeah they didn't have to and they didn't
want to but they did um
and once what i decided to do that they
started
having to have a reason to bring me back
so they would
write something for me so my character
instantly became more
purposeful like i would show up and i
would i wasn't just playing mummy on a
chair i'd had like i would push two kids
i pushed two kids on tv
for example
no but i had a reason to be there and
honestly like i have to say charlie
sheen is like such a master sitcom actor
yeah you'd said that yeah
and all my sins were with him and it was
like
he was able to connect to the audience
in such a
truthful way
he was able to be so himself what did
you learn from him how do you think he
was how do you think he did that like
what is what's the mechanism that allows
somebody to be able to do that
there's there's a certain amount of
self-awareness you have to have in your
performance
um but there's also just a genuine
honesty like there's just something and
and he had such respect for the people
who were watching i i don't even really
know
what
it just was really beautiful and the
audience was so connected to him i
remember one time there was a scene
where
the joke of the episode was he thinks
he's dying he goes to the doctor and the
doctor's like oh something's not looking
good
um
and so he calls my character and he's
like
ready to propose to me it's like i'm
about to die
and he gets down on his knee and then it
gets interrupted so he's like hang on a
minute the doctor calling saying
everything's fine and he's like oh never
mind
kind of a funny joke yeah yeah but in
the scene when he got down on his knee
there was this noise from the audience
from hundreds of people i haven't heard
anything like it in my life where they
all just were like
this emotion so invested in this
emotional response
and he and i just both started crying
and then i cannot tell you how flat that
joke fell after that where the doctor
calls like i bet
you know i'm like surprised to hear that
but i shouldn't be i remember you
telling me that about charlie sheen and
i think the press that he got and the
the pers the public image of him had
just overwhelmed
how i ever felt about him as an actor um
he's he has given wonderful performances
and and it shouldn't surprise me but it
does that he he was so grounded
yeah i mean i think
the person who was in the press saying
all the crazy stuff was like a complete
stranger
yeah wow wow he was one of the first
like
famous people i met i was young i was a
young actor and it was
one of the first times i've been in la i
think if not
the first or second my friend took me to
this
hollywood party and there were all these
like fancy people and
and i was like oh god i saw charlie
sheen and he
he found out that i just moved to l.a i
was trying to be a young actor he found
out he asked but he was so curious about
my life about
my he i found out
brothers he started giving me these like
cautionary tales about don't do what i
did basically
and then he he talked to me for a good
half hour
and and gave me advice and
i never saw him again i can't believe i
didn't know that story i really love it
yeah um he did something so like
exceptionally kind
once um
my ex-husband jimmy who you know yeah
and i used to
they don't have people delivering meals
anymore but we you know donate
uh to project angel food which is a
great organization in los angeles i used
to deliver meals every friday and jimmy
did a different uh route delivering
and there was someone on jimmy's route
who was such a big fan of charlie's and
so i went to work one day and i said you
know jimmy delivers to this guy and he's
such a fan of yours and
he has aids and cancer and he's really
struggling and i wonder if you would
mind signing a picture
but he signed this he was like oh my god
of course and he signed the picture and
then he asked for the guy's phone number
and
called him and it was like the one time
a week that he was at the doctor you
know oh my god but he left this long
voice message for him
and he kept saying to me like i need to
call back when he's there i need to like
really have a good talk to him
um because you know charlie was sober
and this man was sober
um
and
but you know at a certain point i came
and i said i just wanted to let you know
that so-and-so passed where they'd
listen to your message every single day
um and charlie just started crying and
was like
i can't believe i didn't make that phone
call i can't believe i didn't call him
back and i was like but you did
something you did so much more than i
asked if you
yeah yeah oh man i got chills mel that's
really beautiful i um
and it's also um
you know it's
i'm sure he watched the things that's
the other thing about what we do and
certainly a show like two and a half men
that reaches so many people um you you
described that moment of like really
heavy investment about the proposal joke
um
that's the kind of thing i i i sometimes
forget not to like
blow smoke up our asses and pat
ourselves on the back but i i forget
sometimes the um
that that is a a joy that that something
you bring to people's lives you know but
certainly on a popular show you come
into their homes and you make people
laugh that that must feel do you ever
have moments where you're able to feel
good about that where you're able to
um con
conceptualize that
yeah i mean
you know i'm very very shy so yes
being recognized in public is
just a nightmare for me and the only
thing
that makes it worthwhile is
somebody telling me what
it meant to them you know like having a
personal connection
you know when somebody comes up and they
just know you look familiar and they're
trying to place you it's like yeah
just no worse interaction than that um
what what is what form does it usually
take now when it is positive what it is
like you're so and so from such and such
is it usually two and f men
a lot of the time it's two and a half
men and people say my dad loves that
show never
i love that
but i watch it with him to connect with
him he's had to connect with or whatever
you know
a lot of the time it is that show and
it's always really kind of sweet stories
like that
um a lot of the time it's from young
women who say nice things about how
seeing me on television has made them
feel like they're more okay like
i think just seeing someone who looks a
little bit more like you is always a
nice thing for people it's like oh wow
like she here she is on tv having a love
interest and
nobody's like get that fatty off the
screen
but you know what i mean like there's
like teeny tiny women and there's not a
lot of like women who are
sized like most of the world yeah yeah
yeah so there's a lot of that which is
which is really
always nice before you had your green
card were you living in
were you in new zealand where is that or
were you just
living wherever you were working were
you asking me if i was here illegally
yes yes what was your status
and this is not this is on behalf of ice
okay uh
well you're sweating
it's really hot it's summer
yeah
i yeah i was in new zealand for some of
the time and i would come over for three
months which was the length of time i
could get a visa for
and then i lived in england for two
years oh oh okay so so but was the
if you had that aspect what was the
acting aspiration was it just to do you
you strike me as somebody who just
it was simply about doing good work um
but but did you was was there a secret
ambition to to do it specifically in l.a
to
did you want something was there were
you were you
chasing some kind of gold ring
yeah i mean my secret ambition i suppose
was to be
katrin cartilage do you know who that is
no she's my favorite actress of all time
um
she was in breaking the waves she was in
a lot of likely movies just naked she
was in career girls she had such an
amazing
career in independent films and i got to
work with her
in a movie version of the cherry orchard
a year before she passed away very
suddenly but that was like from the time
i was a teenager it was like catching
cat lids and and uh laura dune were
really the the models for me were you
able to tell catherine
before she passed when you were working
together you were able to have that
moment with her i had some i mean
she was very gracious
she was very kind the movie was directed
by this very eccentric greek man called
michael cacoyanis
and he told me in the audition that i
had the job
but he said um there are other girls in
the waiting room that don't look too
happy when you go out
um it was crazy and then he said what a
great day i found you and catching
cartilage today and i
just like listen to tears in front of
him i bet and i couldn't like i could
cry now thinking i was like oh my god
you want to get to
work you're tearing up mel is tearing up
i can attest that's amazing i loved her
so much i'm so glad you were able to say
that too that must have meant
a lot to her because you were also by
that point
you know heavenly creatures you had done
such you were you were accomplished for
a young actress so that must have
meant a lot to her i mean i did heavenly
creatures and then i didn't work for
years then i did um ever after yes which
we have to talk about that was it oh
okay wait
wait oh that's right
ever after was the next one after
heavenly creatures yeah i did like a
little movie in los angeles that kind of
got a release was it hard then to go
back to school to finish school after
that after having experience with so
heavenly creatures just for people i'm
not telling you it was a peter jackson
movie
co-starring kate winslet you you had
told me
about that about that it's one of those
classic like discovery stories but will
you just
tell people like kind of how that
happened it's um
it sounds so like such an overwhelming
experience
it was crazy heavenly creatures this was
like so early 90s what what year yeah
1993 i think
i was 15
and um
i you know i did all the school plays
and stuff like that and local theater
whatever and then
i never used to go to assembly
and one of the teachers an english
teacher came up to me and she said i
know you're never in assembly and i was
like oh court you know oh cause you were
like skipping you were like i was
skipping i would go hang out at the
cemetery across the road with my friends
the cemetery yeah
just just like smoke and stuff
just to like hang out i don't know it
was right there it was kind of spooky
yeah i don't know it was a bit of a goth
um
but also all sorts of kids hung out at
the cemetery it wasn't like
that cool
but she came up and she said i know you
you're never an assembly but there was
an announcement that they're casting for
a movie so you might want to like go at
lunchtime and audition oh my god who was
that teacher she was this it was this
wonderful woman
mrs hall i should remember her first
name because i knew that
yeah she came up and told me so
i went to this audition and i've been
doing this drama class
uh with this elderly woman called dawn
arthur who just sat there and chain
smoked and asked us to do dramatic
improv and then she'd give us notes and
then we'd try another dramatic improv so
all we did was improv and to be a fly on
that wall i mean what i wouldn't give
to for uh
a video of one of those classes just
like i know teenage
kiwis just doing dramatic improv with a
chain smoking like that's amazing there
must be one somewhere she was such a
character and she was so amazing so
anyway this heavenly creatures audition
they didn't want anyone to
read the script or anything so it was
just dramatic improv i was like i've got
this like great and after the audition
my friend susie and i went back to the
cemetery because we had auditioned
together and susie said you're gonna do
this movie and i was like what are you
talking about and she said i could tell
by the way they were looking
wow and then i had to go and do a real
audition and before that peter jackson
put on kate winslet's audition tape and
said here's how good you have to be
yeah
that's that's crazy by the way yeah
she's a professional actress from
england she's been working in television
for five years like here's how good you
have to be so he did that before your
audition
uh how do you remember the feeling do
you remember how you felt
watching kate what do you look like
i shouldn't
she's so great and you know was stressed
to me that she was a professional
and it's so interesting that he did that
yeah i think he just wanted
he's seen this like improvised
thing you know i've never done an
audition before so did you so you did
the audit she obviously did it well and
then how did you find out you got it and
what kind of confidence did you have
going into that experience for the
audition they had this acting coach
there with me her name's miranda
harcourt
and she's an amazing actor herself and
she coaches children and young people
for movies now
and i think like
any
movie that has a child and it should
have an acting coach for the child like
what she does with kids
like she did that movie lion she gave me
so many tools and so much confidence in
that audition that it suddenly felt
possible to me like it it opened it up
in a way
it just was such a big thing
um
and then the first day that i was there
they gave me kind of a free day
of learning how to hit a mark how to not
look at a camera you know yeah oh my god
yeah what was the most difficult thing
for you looking back what was the one
that you you were
oh was the most overcome the max for
sure like the marks on the ground having
to like get to a particular mark on the
ground so that the focus would be right
and not
look at your feet to see that you were
there i
to me i was like i didn't know that was
part of it
and it seemed crazy to me i was like
people are doing this i just saw this
the making of back to the future like a
documentary about it and they said that
crispin glover
was and there's footage of him just like
walking out of frame because he was like
no i think i should be walking
you know i don't want to stay here and
he would walk
literally out of frame in these shots
and so the crew
according to this documentary they built
a little like fence kind of like there
are around trees in the city
they would
construct little like fences for him to
like clever
yeah for him to stay within that that
area um
but i kind of get it especially if
you've only done theater and you want to
like move you want to yeah and the
theater i had done was school plays it
wasn't like i had done like any kind of
formal you know
yeah yeah and with this improv class i'm
sure i'm that's like improv is whatever
happens yeah so i was very very
unprepared and kate was so confident oh
my goodness she had head shots like she
i i didn't even understand what it was
and she said these are for me to sing
for my fans i was like
what she showed up at the airport in a
leather jacket i don't know why that was
like it just seemed so fancy to me i was
just like who is this i was like in the
oar
[Music]
built to move and to sweat in yet it's
designed with a west coast aesthetic
that transitions effortlessly into
everyday life now i didn't write that
but i can fully support that well you
know what's great about viori they
function both perfectly as workout
clothes yes
they function perfectly as everyday
clothes
i know i don't even think about oh
because you know a lot of workout
clothes you're like i don't really i
feel a little silly going to a grocery
store wearing these wow i don't feel
that way in viori the men's core shorts
are great yeah i never feel
self-conscious like or or sometimes i
feel like if i have just like a pair of
sweatpants on and i'm at the store i
feel like a little self-conscious like
little underdressed well like they think
i'm lazy like i just rolled off my couch
these are you will never look
underdressed in viori if you're out in
public they're sleek they're stylish
they're extremely comfortable their
mission is to create quality products
without extra waste they this is we
buried the lead we should have said this
they offset a hundred percent of their
carbon footprint that's not bad i wish
every company did that i know i wish
every person did that we don't do that
so get 20 off your first purchase at
viori.com
long that's v
u o
r
i
dot com slash long for twenty percent
off
in the early two thousands millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
the movie ended up being a classic what
was that like what was the aftermath of
it like you said you didn't work for a
while was that at all conscious was that
did you want to finish school
it was a tricky thing because you know
kate was on such a trajectory she was so
ready to do a movie she'd been doing
television for a long time and
she was like now here's my movie and
what's my next thing gonna you know and
everyone was very excited for kate and
she'd been working very hard and it was
almost impossible for me to be like
oh me too you know i'm jumping in now
when you've been doing this you were in
theater school and you've been
professionally acting since you're 12
years old and here i am on my first ever
thing
i it felt very difficult for me
to feel entitled to anything that makes
sense yeah and everybody was very very
very careful with me there were a lot of
young actors in new zealand who'd do one
movie and be absolutely amazing and then
not have other opportunities there just
wasn't that much being made and the
chances of another movie being made that
were great for you but it was so slim
you know there was this young actress
called my mind
kerbel and she was in once for warriors
and she was so incredible
and
she should have
never stopped
working and she's working now she's
doing some stuff
but you know for a long time there
weren't those opportunities and there
should have been and so it everyone was
like you know it might not nothing else
may ever happen go back to school don't
get carried away
who are the people saying this like who
is of everyone oh yeah the producers
peter his wife friend uh just were you
did your parents weigh in at all or were
anyone in your family like guiding that
decision well my parents weren't there i
was there by myself
so that alone must have been it was
great yeah
it's like a big cemetery
yeah exactly it was great
yeah my my parents nobody was an actor
they didn't understand my dad was
terrified i would never make money right
i bet you know my mother's very
interested in like glamour glamorous
stuff
the rest of it she's sort of like yeah
that's your job i guess you know i
didn't really have anybody who was like
here's how you do it or here's but
people so many people saw that movie i
just imagine like it must have reached
casting people in the states and
producers who
took notice of your performance it did
but it was such a you know
the world was different then you know it
wasn't we weren't like connected by the
true internet it was very you know i i
lived in new zealand i had an accent
also there was a very particular look in
the 90s for
women who were acting and it was like
very thin very blonde i just didn't fit
into the thing that was popular so well
interestingly like i i've always thought
of you i thought i think you look so
much like drew and and your next movie
ended up being
playing one of her sisters right and
ever after yeah it was like a well it
was like one of the stick sisters the
steps
so it was not like a biological blood
right right and people liked that there
was like kind of a resemblance so
when we befriended each other it felt
sort of like
family i guess i mean i have to say
there are moments in
lady the man are out september 17th that
um you
that you uh
are channeling her there's like and i
think i said this to you on saturday or
maybe i didn't because i didn't want to
like get in your head about it but um
you didn't did no okay good um
have you heard that hash have you guys
talked about that similarity has has it
been addressed no i don't think so i
don't remember i mean to me that's crazy
like i
people have sort of said that to me and
i'm just like i just think she's so
stunningly beautiful and she's so
herself like
there's nobody like her i don't know you
know what i mean
you must have hit it off right away we
really did i i was kind of shocked
because i just was like oh my god i you
know it was my my second like real job
it was such a big deal to me that i had
gotten another job it was four years
after hiddenly creatures wow and that
was in london it was in the south of
france oh wow how cool we filmed in the
south of france in a bunch of chateaus
and beautiful castles and
oh we just had dinner parties every
weekend and went to weird french
nightclubs and drank a bunch of wine and
it was just like a dream just a dream i
bet so then after that how quickly was
the next part of your career i mean like
how quickly did did you
transition to the next part was that now
off to the races it kind of was i
started auditioning a lot more and i had
done a few auditions from new zealand
but it was such a big i would have to
make a tape and send in a tape and there
were there was one time where i flew
over to audition for the crucible with
daniel dave lewis and that was like a
big moment
for me to be allowed to be in the room
with daniel day lewis oh my god man we
talked about him a lot on the show
what was that like
he was so kind and very very present i
didn't know if he would just be
in character already it was for a
smaller part in the crucible um one of
the girls who accuses
yeah good his wife yeah yeah and it was
a very emotional um scene
and he was so present like i just felt
it was electric it was just like
you know those auditions where you're
like i honestly don't care what happens
after this this is one of the greatest
moments of my life just this and i have
to just be thankful for this and then i
was still really bummed when i didn't no
i know i have one of those yeah yeah and
i think that was like a real turning
point for me where i was like okay
i can hang yeah nobody was like what are
you doing here you know it was right
the imposter syndrome starts to lessen
yeah yeah
that's always like kind of fascinates me
about you mel because you are
so gifted but you are
like you said you're shy i mean people
might i think people are always i'm
always surprised to meet shy actors
especially shy talented ones and i
always wonder how that happens in a
person is it the safety of hearing
action yeah i think
when i was a child i had a weird
instinct to try out for a school play
when i was like six years old i couldn't
even talk to my classmates i had no
friends i was painfully shy like
painfully painfully shy and we were
living in england i was away from my
grandmother who
was the most consistent presence in my
life i had this bracelet on my wrist
that
she gave me when i was a baby i've never
taken it off in my life
so i just would like
hold my bracelet and be alone in the
classroom and i just had this weird
instinct to audition for this play
i didn't tell anyone i was my parents or
anything and i got a little past but
even in that audition like the freedom i
felt
in having lines getting to be somebody
else like i was like oh i'm allowed to
do
whatever i want and nobody's gonna make
fun of me or judge me or because i'm not
me right yes it's it's so liberating
yeah what was her name mel my
grandmother's name was anne
oh wow ann
i love that name yeah it's one of my
daughter's middle names i love that how
whatever
spirit she had is being passed into
somebody as beautiful as uh because your
daughter has a spirit that is like
stops you in your tracks it's uh that's
so sweet yeah it really truly it's like
disarming her her little spirit so i
like to think anna's in there um
that's amazing that you had that impulse
i'm now i'm so curious
where it came from if you maybe saw
somebody would you watch tv would you
watch movies and think we didn't really
really no we went to one movie when we
were children we were taken to e.t oh uh
ironically yeah so that was very
exciting and then at school i was like
oh i can be part of the conversation
because i've seen
a movie that was a real water cooler
movie for school yeah but then the next
you know two weeks later there was a
different movie and i was like oh kids
get to see all sorts of things i haven't
seen flight of the navigator
yeah
but because i remember you telling me a
really funny story about
when you and jason first got together
you were like
how was it revealed that you didn't
really know his hadn't seen through his
company you know he was talking about
his dad's passing and the way that you
talk to your romantic partner about
moments in your life that were
significant to you and
i knew that his dad was on that show but
i learned that when his dad passed i to
me
i was a huge fan of his dad's but i knew
him
as like a character actor that's right
that's what you said that you knew you
were familiar yeah that all of his great
physical comedy the stuff that i was
like study i was like couldn't get
enough of as a kid like it's so
inspiring that's right you saw his this
whole other part of his career i've seen
it within the last like few years yeah
i think i mean like tadpole and
slingblade and bad santa and like all
this great work that he was doing and i
thought he was like jt walsh like one of
those oh my god i love jt walsh yeah
so tamiya was like john ritter jt wall
she's great like character actors i i
didn't really know where
he had come from
i had this sort of vague understanding
of it that must have been sort of
jarring then to see him do something
like three's company it's crazy i bet
it's absolutely crazy when we started
watching some of the episodes i just was
like oh this is incredible
it's just an amazing skill set who else
are your i mean you mentioned laura dern
have you since gotten to work with laura
dern or some of your other like heroes i
mean i've certainly worked with some
heroes i haven't worked with laura jim
like my dreams of people i could work
with uh regina hall was like top of my
book probably yeah
yeah i'm so obsessed with her ever since
like um
the movie the best man did you ever see
that like in what year was the best man
now i need to google it yeah t diggs
yeah that was 1999. so that was when she
came to my attention scary movies she's
in all the skirts she plays ana's friend
and oh yeah
oh god she's so funny she's so funny
maurice chestnut my friend is a
fascination with morris chestnut who
isn't the best man not only because his
name is great he's great he's great and
he's in everything there's always a new
morris chestnut movie so at some point
in time did you see best man holiday
which was like a sequel that happened
probably 15 years later did you say you
would love to be in like a tyler perry
movie yeah absolutely i would
be very very excited i love what he did
in atlanta how he built his own
like compound like the whole that's a it
was an amazing thing i think and you
were in atlanta for a little bit right i
was just hanging outside like just
waiting like waving to limos waving it
is suspicious
yeah
i'm not
no yeah we were in it like we love
atlanta we jason's worked there a lot so
we we got married in atlanta our
daughter was born in atlanta oh that's
right and you did that great movie and i
don't want to say specifically where
because i know it was meant to be a
secret um but near savannah which is
where one of my favorite movies was was
uh it comes up a lot on the show because
we've had people from the movie called
uh the intervention oh yeah it comes up
a lot in the show well like ben schwartz
was on oh yeah i heard the ben schwartz
episode i love him i love him and and
clea i just thought i think she made
such a beautiful
i just love that movie and i it's really
it's the first time i saw you do that
great drunk acting which um
we have to talk about which you do
to to the best effect in later the man
around september 17th
um
should i'd be saying that but i just
should be nice
um and if you want to mention streaming
and blu-ray and all that uh
you um
you're so good at covering your accent
too uh which is something you had to do
in that movie
but i'm adopting your accent you also
have an accent
what does mine
it's just funny how americans say like
oh you got rid of your accent you
covered your accent it's like i'm
putting on another accent and it's yours
you're totally right how like arrogant
how american what america is pretty
american it is that's real arrogance
ours is the neutral ours is the standard
yes that's the that's the implication
yeah and everyone else has an accent
right yeah well these uh well walk me
through a little bit because you you did
i'm fascinated by it and i'm really
proud that i've been restraining myself
because i have a little bit of accent
tourette's when i hear i know i can't
believe you haven't been doing it
i thought that that would be all that i
was gonna hear like every question would
be in a new zealand accent and you've
been great i love this conversation so i
don't want to step on it with like weird
i've been slightly conscious of it um
but there are certain words that i can't
help i mean yes is one of them yeah
yes yes yes you can't help it uh no it's
a fun one
what is the difference you just
described this to me but tell people the
difference between
and by people i mean me between a new
zealand accent and an australian accent
what is the easiest way to kind of break
that down oh the easiest way that i
think most new zealanders and
australians
the example that most people use is
saying fish and chips because
australians say fish and chips
and new zealanders say fashion chops
like thus yeah so sort of like more much
more on the flash the dialect changes in
england i have a lot to do with where in
the mouth that said like
the north like yorkshire is all up front
it's all in the front like wales
uh sort of like that like liverpool is
closer to the front front yeah
i had to learn a manchester accent once
and the dialect coach told me that the
manchester accent is kind of clipped
because people are talking through their
teeth because a lot of people worked in
factories it was such a big factory town
and the air wasn't good so people
weren't like
opening their mouths very wide and
taking deep breaths i think if you often
mel is like and this will make you
embarrassed but i
there's no one more respected in the
industry and the the certainly the indie
film world you remind me a lot of like
sam rockwell not just
you know before now people know everyone
knows sam because he's he's doing these
big movies and the oscars and all that
but but does it bother you that you're
not more widely known i i remember
thinking sam saying things like that
like he wanted certain things like well
sam is a lot more extroverted than i am
i think it's safe to say
that is true
that is true so just a little bit i i
think like just
fundamentally who i am
it would be really hard for me to be
a true
famous person i had a movie at sundance
that anna kendrick was in and so she and
i were walking around together doing
press and she was like mob and i was
able to just go boop and get around
people and get to the
restaurant or wherever we were yeah but
i honestly i don't think i could handle
it like i honestly feel like i make a
living
doing what i do i get to do
work that i love and i think it's really
interesting and i you know it's funny to
me when people say your career should be
better like people write to me on the
twitter all the time like and i'm like i
think it's i feel very fortunate totally
and and i think you should and i would
never
i would never phrase it like that
because i don't that no i know that's
not at all what i meant it's just the
idea of there is that there's a
superficial element
you know to this you mentioned kate
winslet right away and like drew
barrymore these are like
people these are people that have to
deal with a whole other facet of life
that like
um i wouldn't want i i don't and
i would imagine you even less so because
you are i just know what a private
person you are yeah i mean the times
when
something in my life has happened and
it's been
public like when jimmy and i got
divorced there was a story on tmz about
it
um and it was miserable i mean to be
fair the headline was nicest divorce
ever
so that was good
but um
they they went but you know they went
through our divorce papers to try to get
a story yeah and that's what they came
up with nicest divorce ever
um and it was a very it was a very nice
divorce but um
also super painful and you don't want it
on tv
life could be a dream
[Music]
i've been spending a lot of time
grilling i feel myself getting better
and acquiring more knowledge and it's so
exciting
really thanks to this course on one
dream and there's no better person to
learn about cooking from than a master
chef from cia so one dream is the
streaming service that our brains can't
get enough of there's just so much to
explore i learned how to make pickles
this summer on one dream you sure did
homesteading course but anyway they have
all these core they have
language courses they have history
courses anything that your brain might
be somewhat curious about uh i bet it'll
satisfy that curiosity thousands of
hours of video and audio content
fascinating documentaries helpful how
to's and they answer every question you
pretty much ever had there's a new show
called crimes the century a selective
history of infamy this one sounds
exciting to me there's one that's about
the plot to assassinate the russian
romanovs romanovs
it's so fascinating there's so many
questions and riddles to this case there
was so much secrecy and misinformation
during this that some people still
believe that the romanovs survived
ramanaps okay so enough about us we know
you'll love one dream so we put together
a special offer for our listeners yeah
one dream doesn't know this yes a free
month trial of unlimited access if you
go to our special url
dot com slash long that's
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash long go to one dream dot
com slash
long
[Music]
everyone's dying to know uh about your
do you know what i'm going to say
experience on lady of the manor
chamber 17th from blue ray and laserdisc
laserdiscs no it's it's something that i
find very
charming about you but it is it is a
condition that you have oh you have
misophonia we've talked about it
on the show about about you
having it oh really
listen to your show a lot i've never
heard that
i've listened to it a lot it's
definitely come up how long have you had
it when did you discover it
like my whole life all my siblings have
it my dad has it very very badly my dad
is really intense about it oh how would
you describe it to people like how would
you describe what misophonia is and how
does it manifest in you specifically
well there are different sounds that
it's it's basically they're still
learning about it so only just recently
began to be taken seriously but i think
basically like the wiring in your brain
is kind of off like you hear a sound
there are certain trigger sounds for
people
and it goes to kind of a fight or flight
response instead of going oh that
business chewing
you're like i'll kill them or
or i need to leave like
it
there's this crazy rage
that comes over your body like sometimes
i'll talk about having misophonia and
people will be like i think i have that
and i'll say does it feel like a
paralyzing rage that washes over you and
you have to leave because you're not
sure what you'll do and if they're like
yes then they have misophonia they're
like oh it's annoying then they go you
said that to me and i was i was
diagnosed i was i misdiagnosed myself
with it yeah
i didn't realize that misophonia because
no one likes to hear someone snapping
gum or whatever like it's annoying i
have kind of a misophonia coach in um
sarah silverman who has misophonia she
has it very badly and she's really
really good um at being very direct
about it and asking for what she needs
because she's a very clear communicator
yes um
unlike me
so what would what are you supposed to
do you're just supposed to just clearly
say like but don't like apologize don't
just say like this really
bothers me like i'm i'm sorry you're
gonna have to you know not chew gum
around me or whatever my siblings all
have it too and we share stories like
my brother was on a train trip with
somebody eating a bag of peanuts you
said that to me like it was like a human
brain
for someone with misophonia the idea of
sitting opposite someone on a train for
a number of hours who has a big bag of
shell peanuts in their shell captive oh
god and he just had to he was like when
are you going to be done like he just
exploded at a certain point i was like
oh sorry now have you ever communicated
that that directly to somebody and they
had a like an aversion to it where they
i would imagine most people are very
especially on a set would be very
understanding yeah
a lot of people don't think it's a real
thing this problem people just think
like oh everyone's annoyed by something
oh i'm glad we're bringing awareness to
it i try to be sort of straight with i
try to say it before they've eaten
anything because if they say it after
someone's eaten or in the middle of
eating they get so self-conscious and
then they get a bit defensive the best
thing is if i've seen someone eat and i
know they're a problem either and then
i'm alone with them and they don't have
food if i could be like oh i don't know
if i've mentioned i have this thing
and there you are imagine like i'm sure
you have to remind i'm sure it took
jason a few
i'm sure he slipped up a few times
he's a great eater i would not be
married to him if he wasn't i'm sure he
couldn't be i couldn't be i couldn't i
nothing would happen
um
so
he was great he was always great and
then there was this one day he was at my
house and he got a bowl of cereal
and i just
he said it was just like
i looked like
like panicked kind of and then i just
left the room
and he's like oh i wonder what's going
on and then he realized
like he takes such big
bites of everything that's the only
problem i have with his eating he takes
such a large bite that he's struggling
to keep his mouth closed a lot of the
time
but then how do you tell someone to take
like bites that are not
in their nature you know especially with
cereal because it's such a regressive
food to be eating like i find myself
just going right back to childhood if i
have a bowl of and it's usually when i'm
stoned and i you know i'm not conscious
of it i would have a hard time uh not to
defend everything jason does because
he's my favorite person
but um he's pretty perfect he's pretty
perfect i have very few complaints the
thing about lady the manner that i i
want to ask you about because we
christian and i were so we're going to
talk about your performance and i know
you're embarrassed it's hard to hear
people talk about how good you are what
are your memories of because you were
breastfeeding during that time during
this
which made your commitment to doing it
even
that much more touching and i will start
crying if i talk about it too honestly
so uh we'll table it but how difficult
was that um was doing that it was
breastfeeding and doing everything
because it sounds like i was
breastfeeding during the screens yes yes
yeah we had a little
there was a little partition that we
built for you oh my god you guys were
amazing like i yeah i had done a job
before that my first job back and i
was not supported like i would say hey i
have my instant child in my trailer i
have to go feed her oh there's no time
there's no time
there are some male ads on the first job
i had back who just didn't want to help
and like my boobs were leaking i'm
breastfeeding like i didn't she wasn't a
bottle feeder it was just me
and i would have to like take a moment
to go pump it was on mrs america so kate
actually
always had like a little private space
like contractually and she would tell me
go and pump be in there as long as you
want i'll stay out here if i'm desperate
to pee i'll come knock on the door
you know um like really she protected me
she
would get to sit and be like she's gonna
take a minute like
if i didn't and sarah paulson a lot of
the time also was really like uh
protective and did a lot of stuff but
you know there was some like people just
would like us holding up production and
it was a real bummer but to get to a
little independent movie where people
are structuring the day around like
what i need and what my baby needs
even though you had no money in no time
like it really was moving to me oh well
it likewise it meant a lot to us that
you were
able to navigate that schedule i i
couldn't believe it because you also
have so much to do and a lot of it is
like
a lot of that comedy too requires
a level of energy that that um
i
i don't think i would have i don't think
i had i have that in my reserves um
especially if i was
a lot of that energy was draining into
another human being yeah well it's weird
i would weirdly get more tired when i
needed to feed her because the
milk build up it does something so it
makes you very cloudy so i would start
to get a bit spicy and then i would feed
her and i'd be like okay i'm back
she hates sleeping like last night she
woke up at 4am and she said it's time to
get up
jason and i were like no
just not and she had like
fit
and then finally she went back to sleep
at like six for two hours but what do
you do during that two hours while she's
having to fit oh god sing songs like try
to
cuddle her you know we just travel so
much we move around so much we haven't
been very consistent with her and so
she hated sleeping when i was doing her
movie she was out every
hour in the night oh it would break my
heart just being like a distant like
whenever she'd visit you know because
she's like i i'd want to i know
and it was our first our idea was like
conrad would be like guys come on we
really have to and and and the la oh god
it broke my heart to be like okay can
you and also jason i wanted jason there
it was like yeah i don't want to send
them away there's two magical people i
know um
anyway we we yeah i can't wait for you
to see it i can't wait for people to see
you in it because it's um it's a great
like star
performance it's like that's very sweet
it's such a fun part it's such a fun
movie
because
she's a very questionable person who
does a lot of
scary yeah you got you were smoking i
mean she's like she smokes she's a
stoner
which you had to help me with because i
am not i don't know how to do any of
those things and i didn't want to look
like a dummy that's right well didn't
jason help you a little bit too like in
terms of yeah how to because he uh well
that's what i found funny about it too
is that you got you and judy judy's
playing like the opposite it's not
coupled comedy and so she's playing the
the proper lady the lady of the manor
and i you guys are not total opposites
but you're quite
um i mean you're you're in that in life
you're more suited to
each other's roles
yeah for sure like she's she's a lot
looser
than i am
but she oh i love her so much there's
one outtake that we use but there are
other just like takes like in between
that i i would see i could see you be
entertained by her i loved watching you
watching her i'm so entertained by her
and it's also really fun to do a job
with somebody where
it's how i felt when i met you and we
were doing the movie with canon
and ahmed and all the gang
um
but
that's how i felt then
because
i just never wanted to stop talking to
you
yeah like it was like they would say cut
and we just continue whatever
conversation we were having
before they did action
and i felt that with duty too like yeah
you know the moment the camera stopped
rolling we'd just be like
it's such a lovely uh isn't it yeah i'm
so glad to see that chris and i were
like when we saw that we were like oh
god they're good look at them they're
really hitting it up it was especially
with a movie like that where it all
depends on it's the whole thing rests on
your chemistry and yeah you guys just
and we've wanted to work together for so
long but the truth is like we've mostly
been up for the same role so you know
like she would get it or i would get it
or catherine hahn would get it
we would never get to be in the same
job like
it's one of us you know it's funny i
remember when you had that katherine
hahn conversation with her and you
almost said at the same time judy was
like i know catherine and and there was
no bitterness it was like you all like
oh god well how can i be better about
one of the greatest humans and comedians
yeah she's going to get the oscar where
everyone's like well that was overdue
like thank god she now has an oscar this
is a lightning round so we can we kind
of have to go fast
okay yes
every time i listen to your podcast i
try to prepare and now i've forgotten oh
good good and also everything sweet that
you listen at all mel because you had
said that
so sweet um i love when christian
comes on to tell you everything you did
wrong yes yes that's
a lot of people's favorite part yeah um
yeah brotherly critique yeah it's so
sweet you guys are amazing what is your
most commonly used emoji
it would probably just be like a red
heart
but when i text maggie lawson uh we
always text each other unicorns so the
unicorn is because i text her so much
the unicorn is up there too
maggie lawson oh my god wait maggie was
in uh taken the taken movies
no that's that oh
maggie
gray no i'm sorry isn't peggy great
maggie grace okay maggie lawson is my
sweet friend
uh he's like one of my best friends who
i call puppet
um she was on psych
uh oh yeah
you know maggie yeah yeah yes yes oh i'm
sorry to maggie lawson yes thank you
she's great yeah yeah um
okay so to her you would specifically
text-wise we always take the unicorn
right like pink hearts and unicorns at
the end of every single text and they
pull each other profit
pop it oh yeah that's right um if you
could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play
mouth
a look
of concern i don't know i don't know
anything about sports but i'm kind of
good at throwing things and getting them
into
things that are far away and i'm kind of
good at catching things
so if there's
anything that involves
throwing and catching
okay football i guess maybe what would j
jason no no no no because then that's
violence what
isn't there a part of baseball where all
you have to do is stand in the field and
and then you go like yeah yes mel is
putting her hands in a cupping form kind
of oh you know or with the glass
with the gloves you only you have one
glove what's the guy that just oh the
outfielder
i guess you could but then you you need
a free hand to throw it so you'd have to
take off your second glove really
quickly and then throw it
or that guy i would be that guy um if
you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be
potato chips oh oh you said that with a
bit of shame
yeah
yeah yeah i'm embarrassed of how much i
like potato chips but then there's some
new zealand snacks that i would i would
miss oh like go go bitty doo's like what
what would what there's a chocolate
there's a chocolate from new zealand
called whitaker's chocolate and they
made a version that has ellen p crystals
inside and l p is a drink in new zealand
a fizzy drink
it's called lemon and pyro and they made
this whitaker's chocolate that has l p
crystals it's very specific wow that's
so cool i'm writing that down i want to
check it out um it's amazing okay and
and with chips a chip brand like what
what would your go what would you buy
like would it be just standard like
lay's cape cod oh like cake card like
the reduced fat
cake cod because they're less greasy yes
but they're very crunchy yeah just plain
plain flavor yeah what's a movie that
you're really excited to introduce your
daughter to oh i guess waiting for
goffman
oh yeah yeah
um if you were to go sing karaoke like
in a private room so you don't have
you're not exposed to everyone
what would your go-to song be
it would probably be [ __ ] problems by
uh asap rocky featuring drake
kendrick lamar and who's the other
person on it
oh and two chains i forgot about this
that you
also you i have a kendrick lamar t-shirt
oh yeah
yeah
um yeah because i did that once at
karaoke and it was like it's just a song
i know very well so it was pretty good
who was your first uh celebrity crush
that you can recall oh oliver platt i've
i've told him this also it knows how did
he respond he seemed um kind of
happy about it i don't know
but also kind of like how old
it was like i know it's well wasn't that
funny in what in flatliners
and the three musketeers
and there was like a few other things
he's a very attractive name
i mean i like i had posters of him on my
wall
no i where would
where would you even get an oliver plaid
poster at the movie theater
i went i asked i went and asked at the
end of the run
or
three musketeers and uh flatliners
wow they must have thought you were a
kiefer sutherland fan because i believe
they were both
in that movie
um that was my first like true
amazing
yeah uh if you had to get a tattoo
another tattoo
uh what would you get
have you thought about getting another
yes i would be covered in tattoos if i
wasn't an actor oh wow that's what you
have
yeah i love it so much yeah um i want to
get something from my daughters
so
it's probably going to be a tree
oh
cute okay um all of your back your
entire back yes yeah
weeping willow all going into your sides
um exactly yeah what is your uh what is
your favorite fruit
speaking of kiwis yeah
um are kiwis big in new zealand
well we call them kiwi fruit because the
kiwi is a big person
right of course a flameless bird a
flightless bird that's almost extinct
um
yeah kiwifruit is not my favorite they
make my mouth itchy
um how often do you see kiwi birds
are they that you don't you have to go
to like finch thank you oh wow they're
that ex they're that endangered yeah
they can't fly or run very fast like the
dodo like
yeah like
other animals are just like
easy
melanie just mimed like very casually
eating like a like a handful of chips or
something yeah
um so it's not a kiwi probably
uh
peaches or cherries uh who would you
want to play you in your biopic
oh god is that a new question you always
ask nah it's pretty new the the melanie
story them
oh god olivia coleman oh yeah okay um
and who's your favorite uh muppet
did you watch the muppets growing up you
didn't really yeah not really and this
is a weird question i know i know it's
alienating to our foreign foreign
well that we had muppets i just don't
really know who qualifies as a muppet um
what about the simpsons
yeah i mean i watched a bit of the
simpsons but yeah like
i don't know i like that little kid i
like that little kid that goes
oh nelson yeah nelson is great um
oh
but the muppets like is that is the
swedish chef for muppets oh yes okay i
like that an amazing muppet because it's
interesting because jason ramon has such
muppet energy
to me
he reminds me in the best way you know i
um
what is your
he must like the muppets yeah
yeah i'm sure
he has a lot of like nostalgia yeah
american nostalgia yeah what's your
go-to pizza topic speaking of american
um ricotta cheese and arugula okay is
there a plastic kale if they have kale
like crispy kale
are you vegetarian now
i've been a vegetarian since i was 10
years old 10 years old that's right
okay too much to get into okay
you prefer dogs or cats dogs sorry cats
beetles are the rolling stones
i mean i guess the
beetles but there are some rolling
stones um i mean can i say velvet
underground i would choose
we're talking about like classic okay
yeah i've been listening to a lot of
them what if you could hear a song right
now either beatles or or
what song if you were in a bar right now
what in the jukebox i was in a bar right
now like what would i be yeah you want
to hang out you oh you have a couple
songs to choose
i probably would put on angie for some
reason i feel like i would that would be
a nice one to hear right now
uh if i had to choose a beetle song i'd
probably put on i want you
i don't know it's the middle of the
afternoon it's kind of gray and rainy
here
um a velvet underground song uh what
would i listen to right now
oh you know like pale blue eyes oh so
good yeah
well
[ __ ] i know i i i miss you so much i
like i miss you this is hard to like
stop talking but i know i know i love
getting to see him out and uh yeah just
thank you for everything
oh thank you
[Music]
um so that happened
that happened
[Music]
but she's right you know it's not
i she was so right to shame me for that
it's not an act that that we call her
the way she speaks an accent oh yeah i
thought you're gonna say she's right
that she thought that you were going to
mimic it more yeah back to her the
entire time i thought for sure you were
gonna do that and
uh she admired your restraint as did i
well i i know that's something i
struggle with and i know that's
something i'm prone to doing if i am
conscious enough of it in the beginning
i can avoid doing it you know any any
time there's like a then i was leaning
there was a big i had a big any any of
those
you are like vowel r sounds that she
says are so
cute and funny to me i thought you would
repeat her when she said kendrick lamar
oh yes that's one of my favorites
that's it's also hilarious that that's
her character
yes um i love an ac rocky
kendrick lamar i know it's such a cute
accent in her laugh so it's such an
adorable accent and it like perfectly
matches
her i know i like the perfect accent i
know but you know she is also people
watch lady the man are out september
17th they will never guess if they don't
if they don't know her they will never
guess that she is from new zealand i
know covers that totally perfectly i
know you know there were there were like
a few words when we were shooting it was
so easy to direct her i mean in every
way but like
she's just
so present and always so real um so any
note you give her is just an adjustment
of something that's already
real and not but but when it comes to
the accent that that's a more like
it's it's a more mechanical thing almost
so to say to her
you know i could hear
uh this word you know and i would i
would
point out the word or you would uh well
that she talked about that like that
good cop bad cop yeah you usually did
where you were like
so many times and we were on such like a
time crunch all the time i didn't
realize everything was so limited and
you you're so charmed by her that
there's so many like yes after some so
many takes you'd be like laughing with
her and like like a fan i'd go back and
reconnect like like chris farley like
the christian and then i would have to
come over and be like ah we actually
need yeah i know i'm sorry because i
know that you're so charmed by her too
and so yeah but someone had to do it
i know but what was the word that uh
it's it's the word b-e-e-n bin b
yeah because bean because
um
the english pronunciation is bean
it's it should be bean it should be bean
i again i don't want to say accent
anymore because like are we american
splaining
yes but i'm just i'm american explaining
about um a non-american accent i'm glad
her husband jason made an appearance for
me too there's no better cameo i was
texting with him both about bachelor in
paradise last night and he was being so
funny
about um
chasing we were talking about chase and
yeah if you know you know
if you're a bachelor that's a perfect uh
usage of that expression yeah because
you don't want to go on anymore no if
you know you know yeah
yes i rarely hear that i never say it
yeah you really nailed it you're like
one for one oh good all right i'm going
to read it because i hear that used
incorrectly often i know and you really
nailed it yeah okay you know you know
jason yeah jason i mean what what more
it's also like what more can you say
about it yeah i mean you can kind of
yeah describe him even if you know him
like it's not really worth going jason's
own family says about him when you know
you know if you know you know
his own family would be like geez okay
enough about jason
um but yeah jason ritter's great uh
chase hopefully chase and redder
hopefully a future guest i know oh yeah
he we got to get him it's that's going
to be tough for me because
it's going to be
talk about being charmed by someone i am
i'm just so charmed by them both i i you
could probably hear it you are charmed
by them yeah i feel like they rival uh
kobe smulders and taryn killum as yes
mike you're like
yes but then you add their kid in oh
whose name we won't say no but there but
it's a great name aside from our own
nephews
i don't speak for you my favorite
it doesn't get better no if in fact if i
had a top 10 list of favorite human
beings including my own family
um i i think she would i know she would
be on there she is i think all three of
us would be honest special girl but she
is like of course she is because look at
her parents and they're both so great
that was another problem i had because
the
schedule was so tight as you mentioned
that um whenever she the unnamed child
member would come to sad it was so hard
for me to pull myself away from her
you had to be pulled away from her
yeah i know you often pulled yourself
away oh man she was the best i went to
target um on one of our days off and got
them got her uh
just like a little
elephant because because mel said she
likes elephants it was so cute and i got
her just like a little whatever and um
and then mel sent me a video like
months months later uh where she was
playing the baby was playing with it in
the in the tub and she was like and mel
was like you gave you date and she's
like
justin and i would like melted
rachel she's an angel yeah
you know what would be fun to have a kid
on the show it would be fun yeah to talk
to and not like a famous no no not like
an actor or a kid
hello my name is
charnel
crazy story about um how she got her
start i didn't know that
i mean i knew she did that movie with
kate winslet yeah
it's crazy that she was this
shy kid who did school plays because she
didn't have friends and it made her feel
comfortable and free and then all of a
sudden peter jackson is like oh you have
to do it like that like kate winslet i
know kind of a crazy thing to say in my
opinion someone i know but the fact that
she got that save it for the peter
jackson
that she got that part
opposite kate winslet uh
out of nowhere well that's the thing i
want total obscurity it reminded me of
moments in my
youth where i was like when we'd have to
do a recital or something you know
christian had played instruments and and
we'd have to get up in front of people
and i remember that feeling of um panic
washing over me
and and just being paralyzed by it at
that age because i was and so mel
knowing that she was such a she was like
she's a shy person she really is i've
seen her
interact with people in the world and
like she's very kind very sweet to
people but like she is genuinely shy
yeah and when she said that about like
not being suited to fame like i
totally see that yeah she's also so
where does that come from well she has
such an ability to access the truth and
i imagine that when she was a kid
getting that role right even having
never auditioned for anything before
which is nuts that she got it right her
first audition
uh i think she must just have had a very
natural ability i think that's just the
truth i think so that is the only like
once in a while like a child can do a
kid can do this where there's it's
almost like they're so good at just
playing pretend but that's why like
haley joel osmond there's once in a
while there's there's a kid fred savage
right um there's also something about
her i would say that is
i've met a lot of actresses you've met a
lot of actresses there's really nothing
she loves acting clearly and she admires
actors clearly but there is nothing
accuracy about her nothing nothing yeah
except for the fact that she's a great
actress i know but there's nothing she
doesn't have that thing where she's like
not at all where she needs to be heard
and needs to be seen and not in the
slightly like you know that very
accuracy thing to like ask questions
just to
like over and just over listen to the
response you see that all the time you
hear that all the time she has none of
that i know she's like i know i would
not surprise me if she had any other job
but like then you see your act and
you're like holy [ __ ] it's amazing it's
such an anomaly it's very strange god
this is going to be hard for me to end
this episode i just wanted to give you a
heads up you might have to take the
reins okay because i love melanie so
much it's hard for me to say it was hard
for me to stop talking to her um i have
two two more observations okay great
um one
i love that she
her first crush was oliver platt
and i'm confident that we'll never get
that answer again nothing against oliver
platt no disrespect no but i love oliver
but it's it was that's a great first
crush that made me laugh so hard and she
accessed it so quickly yeah
kendrick lamar
oliver platt
and um i also loved that
because this is that she loves that
movie which one the best man that's
funny yeah yeah and how she wants to be
in a tyler perry movie i would love to
see her in a timely movie by the way
tyler perry
should put her in a movie hopefully a
future guest
that'd be great to get him everyone
should put her in a movie what sums her
up who's such a small thing but
when she
picked dogs over cats and she apologized
to cats for not picking oh that's
doesn't that say everything you need to
know about her
as a person
that is such a good that is such a good
call yeah that is the perfect
summation of mel
hey let's read a letter
sorry cats
okay from jg van gaas
amazing name
jg
van gaas
subject never thought i'd make it this
fast g-a-s-g-a-s-s
okay yeah guess
subject never thought i'd make it this
far more than once
hey guys i'm an overnight stalker at a
grocery store and started doing it just
before the pandemic hit after a few
months i started listening to podcasts
to pass the time i started with armchair
expert and found out about your show
through it once again thank you dax that
wasn't jg that was me back to jg when i
finished it i started your podcast and
fell in love with it fast oh thanks jg i
listened to every episode in order and
i'm about to hit the start of covet i
love the message your show is
broadcasting i consider myself a
fatalist nihilist and everything happens
because it was always going to happen
wow 20 years ago i never would have
thought i'd be where i am today i was
wow
okay i was suicidal and a drug addict
and dealer
wow
my life got better after a few years and
then got a lot worse but eventually got
better again
and now i can say it's close to the best
it's ever been that's funny we were
talking about roller coaster the roller
coaster
that's a real roller coaster not like a
bachelor in paradise role no not the way
they used it yeah um okay back to jg
this is amazing i have a beautiful
partner and i'm about to buy my first
home a real home good for you this is so
cool
something i haven't had in such a very
long time and something i was never able
to provide my own child before
i still get sad but hearing you both
while i work helps pass the time and
reminds me why i do it why anyone does
it because life is short and you blink
and you're almost 40. or in my case
you're 43. you're almost 50. yes okay
back to jg your kid lives in another
country but you're still here trying to
get by and find and cherish the happy
moments while they're here i just wanted
to say thank you i hope both of you can
find that happiness when it's there for
you too and i wanted wanted you to know
you're bringing it to others good luck
out there i'm excited to catch up to the
current episodes over the next few
months
jg
that was uh i i have like i have like
pre-goosebumps
i could feel myself like if i if there
were any more i'd get goosebumps that
was really um
that was really means a lot thank you
uh back to jg jg yup that's my name and
it's just the two letters
huh
ps i know it's self-centered but if you
do happen to read any of this in an
episode for some reason don't email me
back or let me know i'll be caught up
eventually that's hilarious [ __ ] it and
pull it
oh it's really so i guess he's up to
this episode
um
that is really cool what a great letter
i
i'm a lit do you know what my one
complaint about the letter is
uh no
that he doesn't explain his name a
little bit more oh i he does though he
does right he says just the initials so
jg
how is that how do you
how is that possible
don't you think you can name a child
like pj or jpeg or a more traditional
guess without without those letters
representing a word oh i guess so by the
name rather but i've never heard of jg
as that i haven't either maybe he had um
like innovative parents yeah okay yeah
that's true i shouldn't have he does
explain it he said they're just the
initials you're right if he could
explain a different way and say the j
stands for jonathan and the g stands for
geoffrey
but he didn't he just said it's just the
initials if you were to name a kid uh to
look at that kind of name two letter
name what would you what letters would
you choose
um
probably
be it bo bo oh oh really but then people
would pronounce but i know i mean like
where it's just two letters pronounced
like pronounced two letters oh like pj
yeah or like jg i think i do jj
um jj that is selfish because that was
like a little homage to your old man
yeah
um
i don't know that's a good question
uh jm barry
yeah that's nice jm jeffrey miller
i don't know if i would do that no
i think because then people like you
would always be like oh what do they
stand for and it would be a lifetime of
having to well that's your name well
that's what jg must have to go through
jg vangas
right it's not his fault though his
parents named him i know i know but like
our dad our dad is his given name was
rey raymond
uh but he always went by r james
rj in school rj in school but r james
once you became a teacher so like that
gets confusing r is your first anyway
i don't want to diminish how great this
letter was and now i feel like i have no
you didn't take it away from me um thank
you jc um and and
it was so nice to read about your
happiness
and the fact that we're we're supplying
any moments of happiness to you and
anyone else means so much to us and you
know what it would also mean a lot to us
not that you owe us anything uh if you
checked that lady
oh boy sorry no very well done well we
got it oh really because you know we
have to wrap it up yeah and you also
know that we would like people to watch
our movie september 17th and that's out
in like three days if you're listening
on the day this comes out well jg won't
have been caught up he i know but jg
eventually hopefully will like the movie
whatever it's gonna be available
you know what's cool about making a
movie huh it's gonna be available to
watch
forever i've always loved that you both
have to love the idea of permanence when
it comes to making it's awesome i know
it really is so no rush everybody but
that's true watch it watch it too the
lion's kid will probably want us to be
like there's a little rush yeah watch it
they laugh soon
okay
um and uh a huge huge thanks i'm they're
i don't have words i mean words you know
when somebody like melanie it's like
their words just don't suffice wonderful
person wonderful actress yeah wonderful
in the movie yeah wonderful kid
wonderful husband we love her um
thanks mel and jason and uh your sweet
unnamed daughter if she's listening one
day why isn't that cool to think about
maybe one day their daughter goes back
and like listens to to her mom and dad's
this
guy who's so gushy about my mom i'm like
calm down what about me weird like
i don't even remember him
hopefully she'll remember yes and thank
you thank you again to jg and melanie
and
um we'll talk to y'all next week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me
justin long co-director of lady of the
manor it's co-hosted uh by you christian
law also co-director believing the manor
uh nothing to do with lady in the manner
is another producer megan v monaco
senior producer michelle miesh lans
audio engineer and hopefully um somebody
who will be watching lady of the manor
sergio enriquez the executive producer
marshall louis for a company wondering
[Music]
um it's called it's a funny title uh
lady of the hat no manor lady of the
manor
and she's this like uh
kind of like she's just a like job she
doesn't care that much about she works
as um
a historical reenactor of like some rich
old woman who owned an estate in georgia
and like savannah some fancy house
that's now like a historical site
and tours are giving up the house and
she's like hello i'm the lady of the
mana and that's her she like plays this
role and um
and but she really at night she like
goes and drinks and like she shooting a
bar she's like
a modern woman she's a modern woman and
uh
yeah it's a comedy about a modern woman
like beer drinking
sassy and uh maybe she has some romance
with the guy who's really into being a
rain actor and like
is like technically her
not her boss
you lost me okay
uh okay amendment and so the ghost uh of
the actual lady of the manor starts
haunting this like hard drinking mod not
hard drinking but just like
modern woman
and uh she's like the modern woman
realizes that women don't have to be
subjugated and like
confined to like caring about etiquette
and magic she's stalking her yeah she's
talking here because she wants her
legacy to be she she is kind of confused
about like what a reenactor does she
thinks she's like
perpetuating her legacy in like a real
way well she is she is yeah i don't
think she's confused she's just like
seems yeah she's like represent me
better yeah in life yeah
it's funny yeah that's really cool she's
a little confused yeah it's confusing to
a ghost like that
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge watching low
budget made for tv holiday movies the
all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wondering plus in the wondery app
you